hi everybody I'm Liz lamb Pharaoh brand
manager for magic the gathering and
we're super excited this year to be able
to bring to you magic 2015 duels of the
planeswalkers one of the things our fans
have been asking us for time and time
again is when am I going to get full
deck building what am I going to be able
to start from scratch fill the exact
deck that I'm looking for and we're
delivering on that this year for our
players and fans so just to give you a
brief background on the stories we know
in magic 2015 we're checking out where
are our buddy Garrett while speakers our
planeswalker Carrick wild speaker and
you know he's a green planeswalker but
he's been corrupted by liliana Vale
liliana vess Nick and me cursed the
chain vale so he's now he's now moved on
from hunting large beasts and instead is
hunting other planeswalkers which as we
know in magic means he's hunting you so
pretty scary to have the best hunter in
the multiverse on your tail so let's
take an overview look at what the game
offers this year so single player of
course or you can challenge different
foes and build your card collection and
therefore your decks multiplayer is back
this year so you'll be able to play
against up to three different opponents
within your own platform the shop there
are two ways that players can gain cards
for their collection one is through
actual gameplay will go to earn boosters
and another is through purchasing
premium DLC in the actual store the deck
builder will show you here in a second
which is the awesome new feature for
this year along with the card collection
where you can splay all your cards out
in front of you and see what you've got
helping options where for our more
advanced players if they want to be able
to change their settings so that they
can manually edit their lands within
each deck they can definitely do that
here and then the player profile how
have you been playing how have you what
have you what's your tendencies like
what are your what's your card
collection looking like and how how
close are you to achieving all of the
different achievements and titles that
we have to offer this year store locator
you know that that is one of the things
that sets magic apart from all the other
digital TCG's out there is that you have
these two incredible ways to play magic
one on a digital console like you have
here which they'll be coming coming soon
to a to a app store near you on xbox one
xbox 360
pc via steam the apple ipad the amazon
kindle and android via google play but
you can also go to any of the six
thousand stores that we have available
globally where you can play magic every
friday night with friends from around
the world and then extras where we'll
check out some of the latest and
greatest videos that indian videos that
you'll be able to check out in matter
2015 so why don't we check out the
battlefield first and then we'll get a
sense of what's coming up next for us
we're going to hop into the campaign so
this is the single player campaign and
there are five different planes that
each clip that a player can explore
innistrad theros ravnica Chandalar ins
and a car so let's check out a little
bit of innistrad here one of the things
you'll notice about magic 2015 that the
artwork has this very high contrast
black and white feel so as you're
playing against as you're getting ready
to get into your next level you might
see a piece of art be recognized but
definitely in 15 if I'd and treated in
that very distinct look so why me why
don't we head back here to the boss
battle let's check out absent and see
how we play so let's check out the
battlefield here as a take on avacyn so
putting out my 32 she's probably in a
block with her 33 flyer but one of the
things to note this year is garrix
tribal markings take a big prominent
stage here on the battlefield the red
zone is there the attack zone like as a
little nod to our magic fans who use
that slang term she's putting out staff
the Sun majors alright so if I want is
you men on a card that she's put out and
understand a little bit more what it's
doing I can hover over it with the tool
tip of my mouse zoom in and get a better
look at it she's attacking as a flyer so
obviously i can't block so i'm just
gonna let her go ahead and do that send
me a slow painful death of 33 flyers
something else to point out here for new
players is that this year in your head
you can see that you've got 48 cards in
your library or cards in hand one in
your graveyards these little icons here
make it really easy to understand how
you're doing you also have the stages of
a turn so you can see where you are in
your turn as well as your life counter
bringing you down here and then your
actual counter right here so don't miss
this land drops look at this I forest
out there even hold off on Titanic
grocer spider spa night they want to
drop a wandering off instead I know
she's going to block and she's going to
kill one of my guys but I'm going to go
in here and attack a ball and I confirm
the attack yep so she's going ahead and
blocking my child in the night but we
got some damage in now let's look a
little bit more fair
here you can see that I've won the mash
all right hit continue and now we know
where Garrick is off to he's heading off
to theros so now that we've defeated the
boss battle on innistrad we can move on
so back here on the main menu will move
forward into decks and then we'll check
out the card collection so we were
playing with a green black deck it's
happened to that check it out we're in
an edit this deck so we've earned some
cards through our gameplay we've opened
a couple of booster packs we've been
able to defeat some of the different
levels within innistrad theros but now
we want to check out this deck and say
let's make some modifications to it so
I'm going to what I want to do it to my
card collection first so this top paint
here this is what the cards there in
your actual collection here on the lower
half or the cards there in the deck that
you've pulled into the deck builder so
let's open up the card collection pain
and understand a little bit more of what
we've got one of the great things about
this deck builder is that it lets you
filter for the exact card that you're
looking for so you can scroll left to
right and see what cards you have in
your deck but you can also then filter
them by preacher looking for creature or
sorcery that's an uncommon maybe it's
blue you have one and that's chilla
forebodings you can take a look at what
that is we're going to do it back out
let's keep looking for some new cards so
let's clear those filters and let's go
here and now that we filled instead
filtering them sorting them by color you
can sort them by rarity type and cost so
it's almost like shopping for the
perfect card that you're looking for
today for your deck so what rares we've
got unclick it and lets us go through
there so suggestive cards are cards that
you may not have taken a look at but the
cards that are best what the AI believes
to be the best fit for the deck that
you've created so you can see here we've
gotten us and ask mr. fan mayhem
and the mall Schultz wins but you can
also change that up and look for new
cards so if you had new cards that you
could actually just recently acquired in
the last mattress so since the last year
in the deck builder it would pull this
up for you it's we're going to clear
filters now let's take a look at our
card our deck down here I'm going to
take a couple of cards out just kind of
arbitrarily so don't touch the cards on
kicking out we move them all right now
we can take a look at the cards that you
have in our deck but if I'm not sure
exactly what i want i can evaluate how
this deck is currently doing on the
stats filter so here you can see I've
got how many creatures of God the number
spells total number of cards in the deck
you are playing with a 60 card deck so
it does recommend a certain number of
cards for you speed strength control
synergy you can go below that you can go
above that but it is going to tell you
whether or not you should it's your own
edit at your own risk so to speak the
mana curve is one of the hardest things
for new players to understand so this
year what we've been able to do is
really illustrate why that's important
for players so they might not understand
that you know if I have a 66 creature
and I can't get it out until turn seven
that's probably not a card that I want
to have three or four of in my deck so
we'll help illustrate that man occur for
them you can also see your color
distribution how evenly balanced you are
within there and then one of my favorite
things is being able to go ahead and
name it the deck so let's call this guy
gamespot rules then let's go ahead and
slick the right deck box or this all
right let's get some cura we've named
our deck gamespot rules obviously it's
going to be an awesome deck here so
let's take a look at how we can have EA
I help us out with that so I'm not
really sure what exactly I want to pull
back from my collection into this deck
but one thing I can do is ask it to
autocomplete for me so the deck will be
auto completed based on the carbs
they've already added to my collections
when I click auto complete and it'll go
ahead and add them for me that I can hop
back in here and check out what it did
compared to before so 36 total cards
it'll manually add the land for me
unless I go into the settings and then
ask it to change the land to manual
edition so they won't automatically add
that land for me
so let's click done we're going to save
and quit cool now what if I wanted to
create a deck from scratch so let's
check out how i would do that so I'll
happen here to custom deck and then
looking through my collection let's find
out let's find the coolest part that
I've got so let's pull down on phyto
tight so if i wanted to build an entire
deck around Fido titan how would i go
ahead and do that well i'm going to say
auto complete and it'll auto complete
the entire deck for me based around this
one card
so you can see what I've gotten my deck
here so I've got four copies of the
necromancers assistance you can see as
cartas change and the number of
quantities you have this little tab down
here at the bottom will tell you exactly
how many copies of that are in your deck
and there's our fight oh tight take a
look what this card can do all right so
handsome back out 72 he's a big guy all
right we're hit done and we're going to
save and quit
okay so why don't we check out the cards
there in our collection so we'll hop
into the card collection here you can
see the total percentage of cards we've
collected there were 300 unique cards
available to players this year and with
up to four copies of those that adds up
to quite a total number of parts you'll
be able to get over a thousand so here
we can view the cards by all you can see
there's a lot of scrolling fast I know I
can sort them by the plane that they
will arrive two months of innistrad or
theros ravnica Chandalar zendikar or
even the premium cards that you'll be
able to to purchase as you can check it
out here these are all great out
versions of the cars we don't have yet
but for example we do have a reprisal
but we don't necessarily have wall of
omens much like in the deck builder
we're able to also filter and sort by
coppa by all the different types of
colors that cost rarity levels you
change the view so you can swap through
them if you wanted to so let's let's see
how we've been playing so let's hop into
our player profile so here you can see
how many personas I've been able to
unlock number of achievements the number
of titles number of cards in the
collection of unlocked 94 out of 975 I
will say though depending upon when you
step how you start there are different
card number different card amounts
available to you let's check out the
stats so number of total time played 27
minutes obviously I was flying through
this game here but you can also check
out your progression how many of the
planes you've explored how fully you've
explored them and how many multiple
multiple air duels you play practice
jewels
simatic 2015 duels the planeswalkers the
absolute best way to start playing the
world's best strategy game check it out
it will be coming out probably around
the same time as the magic 2015 corset
players and fans both new and more
experienced will be thrilled with what
they get from this game we're looking to
compare price wise approximately to what
it was last year but players are still
getting a great value in terms of
gameplay for magic 2015